c'est sur la rive gauche du fleuve
Nièvre qui sépare l'Ukraine que l'armée
russe se replie c'est dans ainsi la
ville de Herson
occupée dès le début de la guerre
effectif se fait aussi sur un territoire
de près de 4800 km². mais ailleurs en
Ukraine comme dans ce marché de
nicolaïve l'annonçait redoutée
parce qu'il compte réduirait
il est impossible de croire que les
Russes rendront quelque chose
personne est une ville déserte le calme
avant la tempête selon cette expert un
repli
au niveau des tactiques militaires c'est
une opération de combat une opération de
repli c'est pas nécessairement une débat
c'est une opération qui se planifie et
qui vise par exemple à se consolider
à un endroit qui est plus favorable je
sais pas jusqu'à quel point ils vont
laisser la ville facilement aux
Ukrainiens
et pour cette expert en sécurité
personne sera elle-même truffée d'engins
explosif et il faudra beaucoup tant aux
forces ukrainiennes pour dégager les
voies d'accès il pense que les Russes
tentent de gagner du temps à défaut de
gagner du terrain
ce soir le président zellinski veut
surtout apporter la Bonne Nouvelle après
des mois de combat brutaux il annonce
que 41 territoires ont été libérés ils
remercient aussi les États-Unis qui
poursuivent leur aide militaire à
l'Ukraine avec 400 millions de dollars
supplémentaires et 4 systèmes de défense
aérienne
four
Avengers
parce que l'Ukraine continue de subir
les attaques aériennes russes et qu'elle
doit tenter de réparer ce qui peut
l'être d'infrastructures avant l'hiver
ici Yasmine Khayat Radio-Canada Montréal